اربعه ايام منذ بدايه اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه
والعربيه والافريقيه من السودان الى خارج
السودان هنا في مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه
السودان ما زالت مئات العائلات الاجنبيه
ورعاي الدول العربيه والافريقيه
والاوروبيه تواصل توفيق اوضاعها في هذا
المركز بمدينه بورسودان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نسقت معها عديد الدول العربيه
والافريقيه والاوروبيه من اجل توفيق اوضاع
رعايه هذه الدول بغيه الخروج بهم من شرق
السودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى بقيه دول العالم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قالت بانها نسقت مع
الجيش ومع مختلف الجهات هنا في السودان
ونسقت مع عديد الدول العربيه والافريقيه
والاوروبيه حتى يتسنى لمئات الرعايه
الخروج
عبر البحر وعبر الطيران وصولا الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومنها الى عدد من الدول
هذه الجهود المستمره منذ اربعه ايام يمضي
فيها التنسيق المشترك بين الجيش وبين
الشرطه وبين مختلف الوحدات الفنيه
والاداريه التابعه للجيش والشرطه من اجل
انجاز هذه العمليه اجلاء مئات والاف
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين للدول الاجانب في
السودان بعد اشتداد الاشتباكات العسكريه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع يتوقع ان تمضي
هذه العمليه خاصه وان هنالك برقيات ورسائل
تصل الى الجيش لتمهيد خروج مئات من
الرعايه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان
عبر الشرق الى خارج البلاد نزار البغداوي
لقناتها العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات